Dr zaretsky didn't remember falling
she'd hit her head on impact with the
ground hard enough to knock the
immediate memory out of her brain but
not quite hard enough to remember
everything else the feeling of mushy
fungal fingers wrapping around her waist
of rising rapidly into the air the haze
of deadly spores so thick in the air
that they'd created a layer coating her
hazmat suit five meters that's how far
she'd Fallen about half the height of an
olympic diving board only there wasn't a
pool at the bottom and she'd landed
badly Dr zaretsky had been lying in her
hospital bed for nearly a month it was
rare to have an encounter with a 30
meter tall SCP goes south and still live
to tell the tale she knew that as well
as anyone seeing colleagues dying in all
kinds of ways around her for years but
try as she might through all the broken
bones all the bruises and scars and all
the indignity that being bedridden in a
hospital brought she couldn't help but
just feel sad were all these scp's
monsters and what was happening to 5771
as she lay there broken it will be no
surprise to many that the SCP Foundation
monitors emergency service calls often
if there is a deadly creature on the
loose the first people to hear about it
are emergency service operators whether
they believe it is another case
something that benefits the foundation
greatly much of the time that was how
scp-5771 was discovered Bryce wheeler a
junior agent not yet ready for field
work was monitoring incoming 9-1-1 calls
in California when a call pricked her
interest it wasn't so much the content
of the call itself it was in fact that
there was a third call that morning
where someone had died on the phone as
soon as the line connected all that
could be heard was wheezing and choking
noises the operator tried their best to
reassure the person that help was on its
way and that they were tracking the
location of the call but it seemed to
provide little Comfort the choking
noises stopped and there was the
familiar static thud of the phone and
body falling to the ground then the line
just sat open totally silent it made
sense why the line was silent as agent
wheeler looked at the tracking data on
where that call was coming from it was a
national park the middle of nowhere
chances were there wouldn't be any
emergency services on the scene for a
good hour at least that gave the
foundation time to swing into action
diverting any emergency services in the
area to other calls and creating
sufficient confusion within the
emergency services to file a couple of
false response IDs so nobody would ever
notice that kind of thing was and is
very standard procedure for the
foundation at this point since wheeler
had caught the call she was given
permission to ride along as they went to
investigate she only had and one piece
of Intel to pass on to the senior agents
as their SUV bumped its way through the
national park a choked word that all
three colors had said mushroom they
stopped about a kilometer out from where
the call had come in from and got out of
the car to see their first body of the
day there would be plenty more before
the sun would go down that night it was
a hiker early 20s in good shape they'd
evidently collapsed on the trail lying
face down there was a small drying pool
of saliva in the dirt must have been
coughing too agent wheeler was just
about to go over to the body and roll it
onto its back when one of the other
agents put a hand on her shoulder this
was potentially a biohazard situation
they could not risk getting infected
they would proceed in the vehicle with
caution they passed three more bodies on
the trail as they went they reported
each one back to the foundation who were
in the process of setting up a perimeter
around the national park and combing the
outskirts looking for hikers for
apprehension and medical
once they'd passed their fifth body the
driver stopped the car again he was
leaning forwards in his seat peering up
into the sky agent wheeler tried her
best to see what he and all the others
were looking up at but couldn't make it
out they were next to a little rocky
Canyon with a few trees sticking up out
of the ground most of them stripped
nearly white by The Heat Of The Sun
actually there was one tree that looked
taller than the others thinner too as
she leaned forward in the seat and her
eyes saw more and more of the tree she
quickly realized it wasn't a tree at all
it was a pair of spindly legs then a
skeletal torso with gangly arms then an
elongated neck and then a mushroom
without thinking agent wheeler opened
the SUV's door and stepped out into the
California heat she was Tiny in
comparison to the creature before her
barely as tall as its ankle its whole
body seemed to be soft and slightly
wrinkled just like the mushrooms you'd
cook with at home her mouth fell wide
open as she stared up at it and to her
surprise it turned around and stared
back it didn't have eyes a face or any
features at all all there was was a
giant mushroom for a head but somehow it
seemed to see her it leaned down and
peered closely at her the agents in the
car were yelling something behind her
but she ignored them there was something
ancient about this creature and yet
something so young and innocent she
coughed then coughed again tiny spores
were floating through the air all around
her within three minutes agent Wheeler's
throat had totally closed off full of
fungal growths the other agents tried to
open fire on the creature but were all
dead just moments after she was all
choked to death all told the foundation
discovered 18 civilian bodies that day
each was reported to their family as
having died of other causes no autopsies
were allowed to be carried out anyone
who claimed to have seen any kinds of
mushrooms when interrogated that day
were administered Class A amnestics the
containment perimeter quickly tightened
as Foundation Personnel moved in on this
enormous Mushroom Man with heavy
Weaponry at the ready the foundation
surrounded the creature it bent down on
its approach with hands out by its sides
this was interpreted as an act of
hostility and the SCP was secured
swiftly and without leniency a special
containment cell had to be constructed
for the Mushroom Man as it was far too
tall for any standard cell it was
detained in an external holding area
until the 32 meter tall cell had
completed construction once inside the
foundation was able to get to work
studying it designated
scp-5771 this SCP measures 30.48 meters
in height its organic tissue seems to be
made up entirely of a gargantuan fungal
growth the head of the creature
resembles a mushroom of the Amanita
pantherina species also known as the
panther cap mushroom the body resembles
a rudimentary humanoid skeleton samples
taken from it have revealed that it is
composed of the mushroom stock material
while the creature's thorax is made up
of a ring of the fungus it has a keen
awareness of external stimuli
particularly living beings a mouse in a
cage was placed inside itself for one
hour unlike all the humans exposed to
scp-5771 spores the mouse did not die or
suffer any form of fungal infection what
was more notable however was 5771's
response to the mouse leaning in as
close as it could it appeared to stare
at the mouse for the entire time that
the mouse was in its cell despite
lacking eyes or any obvious sensory
organs researchers noted an apparent air
of curiosity about the tiny creature or
at the very least A Primitive interest
5771 amidst spores continuously when it
moved into its holding cell the room
filled with so many spores over the
course of the week that it was difficult
to even observe the creature through the
cameras it was deter determined that the
cell would have to be cleaned twice a
week to ascertain how safe this would be
d2304 was sent into the cell in a level
2 hazmat suit within three minutes the
d-class Personnel was dead it was
decided that level 4 hazmat suits were
required and since then there have been
no issues with infections of personnel
from the spores this is where Dr
zaretsky came in a keen Mycologist with
a background in studying the cordyceps
genus she had leaped at the opportunity
to study
scp-5771 a particular breakthrough came
when communication was established with
the Mushroom Man Dr zaretsky had the
idea of using biodata sonification to
try to look for any microcurrent
fluctuations in
scp-5771 the same ones that occur in
non-anomalous living organisms to her
and the research team's surprise as soon
as the electrodes were inserted into the
scp's feet a low slow voice seemed to
appear in the static noise of the
computers nature is from
nature is friend why enthused by her
breakthrough Dr zaretsky set up an
interview slot as soon as possible to
talk to 5771 it appeared to have a
limited vocabulary but did not display
any significant difficulties in
understanding her when asked where it
came from 5771 simply replied nature
when asked for further specifics it was
only able to add that it came from
mother Keen to understand what its
purpose was Dr zaretsky changed Tac
asking the mushroom giant why it had
been born why was it here what did it
want on the surface it appeared to
ignore the question choosing to ask one
of its own why hurt mother taken
slightly aback by this the doctor tried
to clarify what it meant by them hurting
mother the creature was not referring to
her specifically but to humanity
collectively it appeared to use the
words mother and nature fairly
interchangeably so Dr zaretsky asked if
it was referring to climate change
5771 seemed to confirm that informing
her that mother was hurting asking why
humans wanted to hurt mother taking the
offensive zaretsky asked 5771 why it had
hurt and killed so many people to which
it simply said
unintentional
apologies it was then ascertained that
the creature had no conscious control
over the release of its deadly spores
later assessment had also theorized that
5771 does not bend down towards humans
as an attack to expose them to more
spores but is instead trying to make
itself less intimidating it spent much
of the rest of the interview asking Dr
zaretsky for forgiveness for its actions
the SCP seemed very keen to let her and
the other researchers know that it never
meant to hurt anybody and even
demonstrated remorse over its actions in
an attempt to reassure the SCP who
seemed to be growing more distressed by
the minute zaretsky accepted the apology
and said that they were friends while it
is difficult to tell if a mushroom is
joyful researchers generally agreed that
it was the displayed emotion at hearing
those words and perhaps that was Dr
zaretsky's big mistake
5771 so happy to have made a friend
attempted to pick her up wrapping its
fungal fingers around her torso it
lifted her straight off her feet and up
into the air zoretsky screamed taken
aback completely and overcome with the
fear of suffering the same fate as the
18 civilians in the National Park
realizing its mistake the SCP dropped
her from a height of 5 meters she was
rushed to the hospital with the broken
left wrist fractures in her left ankle
left arm and left elbow and some other
minor sprain injuries out of action for
two months Dr zaretsky had no contact
with the SCP as she lay in her hospital
bed meanwhile 5771 grew withdrawn it
would hunker down in the corner of its
cell in an attempt to be as
unthreatening as possible equipped with
a proximity alarm Dr Danielle Baker took
over the interview sessions asking sharp
direct questions Dr Baker tried to
understand why
scp-5771 had attacked her colleague the
Mushroom Man still crouched in the
corner apologized profusely it referred
to zaretsky as friend and repeatedly
asked where she was with growing
distress Dr Baker's interview technique
in this session led her to be
reprimanded by her supervisor she pushed
the questions hard interrogating the
creature as to why it had hurt the
doctor it was only when her supervisor
stepped in that she relented revealing
that zaretsky was alive and recovering
as the interview concluded 5771 had one
request for the departing doctor
friend fortunately none of Dr zaretsky's
injuries were serious within a few weeks
she was back in the cell with 5771
conducting another interview session she
barely entered the room and started to
talk before the SCP interrupted her with
cries of friend and many sincerely
offered apologies for what it had done
to her the pair of them have conducted
several interview sessions since many of
which have been left undocumented as
they contain little relevant data to
help the foundation understand this SCP
or The Wider World much of zareski's
conversations with the creature revolve
around mother no matter zaretsky's best
efforts 5771 seems unable to grasp why
humans are hurting mother it uses the
words burned drowned poisoned and
tortured to describe what is happening
to Mother it claims that this is the
reason that it was Crea created
discussions between Dr zaretsky and her
wider research team have concluded that
scp-5771 seems to have been created as a
response to the climate crisis several
have noted that the Gaia Theory as a
part of this finding which claims that
Earth is essentially one giant
self-regulating organism called Gaia
humans plants and animals all play roles
equivalent to individual cells if one
group overpopulates and begins to harm
Gaia then the body as a whole takes
steps to address the disturbance
scp-5771 is theorized to be one of those
steps being taken by Gaia Mother Earth
nature or whichever title you prefer in
order to address the problem of man-made
climate change with the ability to
empathize communicate and forgive 5771
seems to be socially capable of
encouraging behavioral changes in humans
others have pointed out much to Dr
zaretsky's disdain that 5771 is is also
highly lethal to humans perhaps as a
contingency measure to control
population growth regardless the
Mushroom Man is to be kept within
Foundation containment indefinitely
interview sessions are ongoing but it
seems unlikely that this SCP could ever
be in nature again no matter how much Dr
zaretsky advocates for it now go check
out scp-2800 cactus man and scp-504 bad
joke tomatoes for more